hello and welcome to driver the DW car
show and this addition the new Opel
Mokka with its whisper diesel engine a
vintage edition of the Toyota Corolla
from 1973 plus the new one series from
BMW BMW presents the next one series
with a fresh design and new engines the
compact car has sold almost 2 million
units since its launch 11 years ago we
check out the top of the range model
which packs the powerful m135i inline 6
engine at the other end of the engine
range we have new gasoline and diesel
units with three or four cylinders the 1
series therefore has the broadest range
of engines in the compact segment the
car was also designed to win over new
and young target groups explains BMW
executive Christopher vana a lot of
customers then move up to a 2 3 or 4
Series so the 1 Series is the brand
successful entry-level model over 70% of
buyers are new customers for the BMW
brand automotive journalist mish Faced
is impressed with the new design in his
opinion every car needs a facelift every
three or four years and BMW has
genuinely managed to modernize the car
he says compared to the outgoing Edition
the front is really nice and sporty not
over-the-top but still very contemporary
in visual terms the new edition looks at
class above its own
on the front we have new LED technology
which enabled us to make the front light
slimmer of course we have the typical
BMW double round headlamps the ear vents
were likewise revamped we made the
kidneys larger this makes the front end
sport here because of the larger
openings and in particular I'm very
proud of the very 3 dimensionally
sculpted kidney blades the overall
effect is a very strong and sporty front
end meanwhile the back end is a marriage
of cutting edge technology and design on
the rear of the car we also have new LED
lights with this technology we were able
to make the rear lights slimmer in
particular with the LEDs we were able to
make a very unique light signature and
it gives it a very clear identity at
night time new contouring has given the
1-series a fresh look at the back
horizontal lines create width and
sportiness and the flared wheel arches
give it that solid stance on the road
when we see the final result we have a
very stretched very sporty rear end with
clear BMW identity the m135i x' output
has been boosted slightly to 240
kilowatts and germany prices for this
meaty compact model start at 40 1900
euros although one important feature
will be missing in the next generation
of the one series
I know it's still the only model in its
class with rear-wheel drive he says BMW
will keep it until this model is retired
in 2018 then the car will be available
with front-wheel drive only the interior
has a sporty feel and is fitted with
sophisticated materials the sporty top
of the range model comes with an
especially big display of course but the
standard equipment in the new 1 Series
is now also more extensive with a
high-resolution 6.5 inch monitor aircon
rain sensor and the iDrive control
system
AMV BMW is eager to promote its premium
manufacturer image in the compact class
to the quality of this one series is
pretty close to that of the three and
five series so way above average for its
segment Skoda presents the third
generation of the superb in Prague like
its predecessor it's very practical and
is chock full of clever innovations and
assist systems that are meant to appeal
to many drivers Skoda is introducing its
latest flagship at the Forum carlin one
of the best-known event venues in the
Czech capital more than 500 journalists
came from around the globe to watch the
superb rollout accompanied by music from
the Czech Philharmonic
couple days CEOs chief vana ice horn
says revamping a model has a big brand
impact it's an opportunity to make a
sustainable impressions and continue
development in that spirit the new
superb has been given a complete
makeover with a new design and
technology the first two generations of
the midsize sedan
were big hits the latest model is hoping
to follow and not just in terms of
design but real utility as well such as
the trunk boasting 1276 litres of cargo
space
agaves for head designer Joseph Caban
it's a clear combination between
practicality and aesthetic appeal as
well as looking good that's the heart
and soul for designers it should work
well to getting that mix right is what
it's all about the automotive media is
thrilled about the result as his veteran
Czech singer Karel Gott
then when I speak to Scott as head of
design and see what he created
then I'm proud again that were the
country of the car it's just like back
in the beginning of the 20th century San
Beda VI Mun fungus 160 out of little
people who want to superb have for
gasoline and three diesel engines to
choose from these can generate between
77 and 191 kilowatts of power and meet
the euro-6 emission standards the Green
Line engine is the most economical
explains our Skoda executive and goes
100 kilometers on just 3.7 liters of
fuel and only emits 95 grams of co2 the
most powerful unit is the 2-liter turbo
with 280 horsepower it shoots up to 100
km/h and 5.8 seconds
clever little details like providing two
umbrellas in the front doors are part of
the package as are the latest in driver
assist systems
Android and iOS smartphone networking is
possible too
put in what's important in the interior
is space space and more space elegance
space and a feeling of homey comfort
you'll experience in a somehow familiar
way with the combination of ambient
lighting lots of Technology and the rest
you'll be able to enjoy something really
new and special Asher Scott is design
chief the new superb is available for
order now customers can expect delivery
in the second half of 2015 and Germany
prices begin at 28,000 290 euros
Kujo has unveiled its new hot hatch the
308 GT it comes with a 1.6 liter turbo
engine the exterior has a more elegant
than athletic feel in fact with a
stylish indicator layout at the front
and a high-gloss black diffuser at the
rear the price in Germany is below the
magic 30,000 euro line a few grand more
will buy you the GT and diesel or as a
station wagon the new Audi rs3 is a far
more dynamic affair a butch looking
front grille with huge air vents make it
clear this is the top of the range a3
model hit the gas pedal and you hear the
rich baritone of the 5 cylinder engine
thanks to a 270 kilowatt engine and
Quattro technology the rs3 makes the
dash to a hundred in just 4.3 seconds it
goes on sale in the summer with prices
and Germany starting at just under fifty
three thousand euros
if achieving success isn't easy
maintaining it is even harder says
test-driver Klein ho Dyson hofa Opel has
sold the makkah to over 340 thousand
customers in the last two years to
further boost sales the Moka is now
available as a whisper diesel hmm it's
definitely quieter than many engines he
says Opel says it's also efficient and
zippy we want to test that Opel Mokka
currently has the fastest growing sales
on the European car market reasons for
that are the modern chassis and drive
technology that our key features of the
SUV the new all aluminum 4-cylinder
diesel engine is super compact it
replaces the 1.7 cdti it offers more
power and torque with a smaller
displacement area and a lot lower
consumption
yatin we showed here in our test that
fuel consumption in the Moka has gone
from four point six liters to 4.1 liters
per 100 kilometers says he'll make a lot
from Opel that also affects co2
emissions it's only emitting 109 grams
of co2 per kilometer now Paquito Mehta a
meteor even if the idea of anything
under five litres for 100 kilometer
sounds good
everyone knows that the manufacturers
figures are mostly lower than in reality
so the mocha is supposed to be quiet and
fuel efficient can our test driver
confirm that
the mocha is indeed quiet he says
surprisingly so in fact I just shocked
the camera team because I thought the
engine wasn't running anymore and took
my foot off the clutch it lurched but
everything was ok but that certainly
proved that the Opel Mokka really is
quiet it's also economical Opel says an
average of 4.1 litres is possible in our
test we managed just under 5 litres
under 5 is pretty good the snappy 1.6
CDTI offers 4 kilowatts more power than
its predecessor and 20 Newton meters of
extra torque it can go from zero to a
hundred K and nine point nine seconds
and reaches top speed of 191 km/h but
the mullahs greatest strengths are its
fuel efficiency and low emissions as we
heard it's also quiet
so how do you make a diesel engine so
quiet
that's why in dsm-5 it was only possible
in this case as Opel so Mikaela because
we optimized everything absolutely
everything in the engine from an engine
block that is designed for optimum
acoustics to secondary measures like the
muffler on the intake pipe or the
integration of the vacuum pump and the
oil pump into the oil zoom so that the
oil and the oil ISM muffle the sound of
the pumps this commotion
he's a pump there aren't any new design
elements in the interior subtle chrome
highlights and high quality materials
makeup pleasing impression the vehicle
is also versatile and practical you can
make full use of 1372 litres of luggage
capacity thanks to the split folding
backseat the rear of the car with
underride guard and matte finish
aluminum is typical for an SUV the Opel
Mokka 1.6 CDTI comes with either
front-wheel drive and 6th gear
transmission or 6-speed automatic or
with all-wheel drive and a manual 6 gear
transmission the Opel Mokka with whisper
diesel is quiet smooth economical and
zippy says our test driver in summary
and it's key for Opel because fifty
seven percent of customers order it with
the top equipment line which is what
provides the most profit for the
manufacturer
recently our whole team was in Geneva
for the Motor Show explains Iman well
Schaffer that meant a trip of some 750
kilometers quite a challenge with a team
of five plus camera and editing
equipment flying would have been one
option he says and the quickest the
train would have been the most
comfortable but the problem with both of
these is the restricted mobility once
you've arrived at your destination so
the only real alternative he says was to
drive a lot of cars don't have enough
room which is where the Mercedes veto
comes in this baby certainly has ample
space a great opportunity for our team
to put the cars long haul qualities to
the test as they make their way to
Switzerland from Cologne the veto is
designed as a multi-purpose light van
launched in 1996 it's built at the
mercedes-benz plant in the Spanish city
of vitoria-gasteiz hence the name
with many cars the front seats are the
most comfortable with the veto however
the second and third rows were equally
good it's so comfy he says that a couple
of my colleagues have already fallen
asleep the whole team end up
surrendering to the sleepy feel except
the driver and cameraman of course we
were on the road in the 119 CDI Edition
its four-cylinder diesel engine
generates 140 kilowatts of power and has
a peak torque of 440 Newton meters this
version features rear-wheel drive fuel
consumption is 6.1 liters of diesel for
100 kilometers but then there's the big
question what are the veto strengths on
the utility front the Mercedes veto
comes in a variety of lengths and
versions as a utility vehicle dual cab
chassis with a spacious cargo section or
the tour people carrier we plumped for
the tour and the compact version
measuring four point nine meters long
the exterior has a robust look with the
skirts made from scratch resistant
plastic
we begin our test with packing and a
stroller
the rear seats can be shifted forward
with ease making this task child's play
it's similar with the middle seats one
pole and the entire row can be slid back
and forth and easel fix technology
allows child seats to be easily and
securely fixed in place the rear seats
can be folded down individually if
required
that opens up a wealth of possibilities
for loading awkwardly shaped objects the
tour is a people carrier
that's very cargo friendly to the front
cabin has a nice clear layout oriented
to that of the Mercedes Sprinter the
materials in this equipment line all
boast top caliber workmanship and the
technical features are also solid all
Vito models are standard fitted with a
crosswind assist the designers were
looking at efficiency as well as safety
the entry price for the Vito 109 CDI
panel van in Germany is twenty one
thousand four hundred eight euros the
tour in the compact base edition with a
109 CDI diesel engine cost just over
thirty thousand euros
making the round trip between Cologne
and Geneva we covered around 1,500
kilometers he says so the exterior
suffered a little but its performance
was flawless
ample legroom and plenty of space for
the whole team Amano says he can't
remember many times before having such
comfort on a long journey
Florian Engel is a classic car
enthusiast he's taking something really
special out of his garage and the
Bavarian town of wood siedel nearby roit
it's a 1973 Corolla Levine Toyota
introduced a second version of the
Corolla in Japan in 1970 a year later
the Corolla was marketed in Germany and
sold 20,000 models it was yet another
success for the Japanese car industry
abroad but the Levine model which is
like the GTI of Corollas was only
available for customers in Japan and the
US
Florian ENGOs Levine is probably the
only one in Germany or even Europe he
found it on an American car forum and
convinced the owner to sell him the rare
model even though the car is a decade
older than its owner the Levine's
4-cylinder 1.6 liter engine still powers
it up to 108 horsepower and a top speed
of 183 on the Autobahn the Corollas
lines seem a bit odd yet somehow
familiar
it's a typical compact car with European
dimensions some say the design is
reminiscent of the Ford Escort others
say it's more like an Opel cadet a few
of the details are a bit too quirky
florian says when he takes the car to
old timer events few people recognize it
as a Toyota there's little to reveal
what it is except for the old Toyota
badge on the grille it says Corolla on
the side that's when people realise what
it is the Corolla was supposed to
conquer new markets for Toyota
some say that explains its aesthetic the
curvy fastback rear end is reminiscent
of American muscle cars downscaled just
slightly a full family of Corolla models
were made a sedan station wagon and a
sporty two-door known to insiders as te
27 florian says that when he looks at
the TE 27 he sees that its design has
been influenced by a wide range of cars
it's like that with most Japanese autos
he says the thing that makes it special
is that it's a mix of all types of
styles and as a result has created
something new it's not like Italian cars
that always originate their own lines
but a combination the interior by
contrast is quite Spartan there are a
few sporty accessories like a rev
counter which was a contemporary feature
there's lots of plastic with a hint of
chrome nothing flashy to distract from
the driving experience
the advantage of the sparse interior
trim what's not there
can't break florian says that you really
have to be passionate about Japanese
cars because getting spare parts for
them takes patience there are still
parts in Japan and the American market
for them is big but fluorine says in
Germany it's difficult to get parts here
when something breaks thank goodness
there's very little that breaks when it
comes to large series classics that are
made in Japan the Corolla Levine is
robust Florian can simply focus on the
joy of driving it the V means lightning
bolt and refers to the cars driving
performance the little car from Japan
doesn't have to hide its light under a
stone it weighs 850 kilograms and goes
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in 9
seconds the chassis technology is solid
rigid axle suspended with leaf springs
were standard in compact car
construction in the 1970s
the Corolla showpieces
under the hood to double barrel
carburetors insure that the dual
overhead cam straight four-cylinder 1.6
liter engine purrs with power modeled on
Alfa Romeos of the time motorcycle
manufacturer Yamaha supported Toyota and
developing the cylinder head the growl
lets everyone know the Corolla isn't
just cute
Florian became a Toyota fan early on his
grandfather founded one of the first
Toyota outlets in Germany in 1975
Florian's dad and uncle Friedhelm later
took over the company in the 1980s in
addition to selling maintaining and
repairing current Toyota models Toyota
specialist Friedhelm Engel has got a
side job he restores classic cars
most of them vintage Toyotas this green
Celica is about finished it's being
completely rebuilt for his own
collection
if Florian has a problem or can't get
apart uncle fleet home always has a
solution
the area around home has plenty of
sinuous roads making it perfect driving
territory for Florian angle in his
levine he loves going out for rides in
his rare vehicle
and there's one thing the Toyota fan can
be certain of it's not likely he'll run
into someone with a car like his anytime
soon
in the next edition of driving a compact
SUV with the edges rounded off the new
Lexus NX 200t and a blast from the past
we take a 1974 VW Golf GTI out for a
spin